جولات جديدة سيتم تحميلها قريبًا في
الخرق ،
تنتظر هذه القوات الأوكرانية
الأمر
الذي يستعدون لإطلاق هذا السلاح.
تلقت أوكرانيا أكثر من مائة
متر من مدافع الهاوتزر الثلاثية ، لكننا رأينا
بثبات أن الروس يكتسبون المزيد
والمزيد من الأرض.
يساعد ، لكن قد لا يكون كافيًا
مع
مدافع هاوتزر المتطورة التي صنعناها الولايات المتحدة والتي يبلغ قطرها 155 ملم مثل هذه
أوكرانيا ، وتأمل أوكرانيا في مواجهة
التفوق الهائل لروسيا وقوة النيران
التي سمح تفوقها
للقوات الروسية بالمضي قدمًا في إخضاع مدن
مثل سيفيرو دونيتسك وقصف ليسي
لقصف مكثف
هذا  تُظهر لقطات بطائرة بدون طيار أن الدبابات الروسية
تدخل مدينة
توشكيفكا خارج مدينة سيفيرو دونيتسك
، وهي تفوق عددًا وتتفوق في التسليح في شرق
أوكرانيا ، ويُحذر من أن القوات الروسية قد
تكثف هجومها قريبًا ،
فهذه المدفعية تطلق قذائف يصل
مداها إلى حوالي 20 كيلومترًا أو 12
ميلًا ونصفًا
على الهدف.  قيل لنا ناقلات جند مدرعة روسية
بفضل الأمريكيين أعتقد أنه يمكننا
الفوز  هل الحرب تقول أن الكتاب قد تم ، المشكلة الوحيدة
هي أننا نحتاج إلى المزيد من البراميل المزيد من
المدفعية والذخيرة
أو بلغة إنجليزية بسيطة نحتاج إلى مساعدتك
أسلحة كافية لمحاربة رفيقه
يضع عددًا عليها
العدد الخامس
نحتاج إلى ما لا يقل عن 500 من هذه البنادق كما يقول
هذا  صارت حرب مدفعية
وسيأتي النصر في هذه الحرب
من ماسورة
قلم رصاص ورجل أرملة CNN شرق أوكرانيا.